[موسيقى]
اذا ما كنت من سن الخامسه والاربعين
واستيقظت يوما نظرت الى المراه وجدت جسمها
كذبت في وجهك التجاعيد التي تشعرك ببعض
الكابه وفقد تشرف فلا تستغرب ذلك لانك
ربما اصبحت عضوا في سن الياس فاهلا وسهلا
ومرحبا
لكن ما هو سنه الرجال يتساؤل كثير من
الاشخاص عن هذه المساله ويجب العلم انها
حاله تؤثر على كبار السن مما تجاوز عمر
الشباب ولها اعراض متفاوته ترتبط بانخفاض
هرمون التجسسرون وشيخ وقت مبكره ربما ولها
العديد من العوامل ومنها انخفاض
الاندروجين في الذكور وقصور الغده
التناسليه ايضا
الاحصائيات الطبيه لنا اكثر من 40% من
الرجال في العالم يعانون من هذا المرض
الصامت او ما يمكن تسميته بازمه منتصف
العمر والتي تتمحر اعراضها بين قلق مستقبل
سواء العملي او على المستوى الشخصي الامر
الذي قد يدفع للاكتئاب وليس من الحياه
ربما تصل الى مرحله خطره اذا ما ادراك
الانسان حاله في هذه المرحله
[موسيقى]
ويبقى الامر في طبيعه الحال النسبيه بين
الرجال بيعتمدوا على ما تكونوا عليه
الحياه التي يعيشها الرجل
قد لا ياتي لمن لم يرضى ويقرع بحياته
وتفاصلها حتى وان بلغ هذه السنه وقد قال
الناس فيما سبق لا ياسا مع الحياه ولا
حياه مع الياس الانسان الاختيار بين
الامرين يعني صباح العربيه محمد خالد
[موسيقى]